This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档I-Heart播客，保证真人真事。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。1984年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而退》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有牌照的专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？这向世界传达了你不是好惹的信号。但这并不意味着你具备这种能力就一定要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习知难而退。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一大批人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格Greg，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》？也就是2%？
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Let's be real for a second. The job market, the job hunt, the economic climate, all of the above, have gotten so tough in recent years. And if you're in your 20s, you're probably feeling the pressure and the impact of this more than any other age group. It is so much more difficult than it was for our parents' generation, even a few decades
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理。让我们现实一点。近年来，就业市场、求职、经济气候以及以上种种，都变得非常艰难。如果你正处于二十岁，你可能比任何其他年龄段都更能感受到这种压力和影响。比起我们父母那一辈，甚至在几十年前，要找到一份既能付得起账单又有成就感的工作，或者甚至在自己选择的行业中找到入门级机会，变得要困难得多，更不用说一个稳定的职业道路了。
ago, to find a job that can pay our bills, but is also fulfilling or to even find entry-level opportunities in our chosen industry, much less a stable career. path. And I think this experience of struggling with unemployment and continuous job hunting, the pressure to have it all figured out, the pressure to have some fulfilling, rewarding job lined up, some fulfilling rewarding career is really feeling increasingly impossible in this day and age. So I wanted to talk about it and I wanted to help you understand the science behind not only why it's so difficult, but why there is so much shame and frustration and at times even anger and resentment when it comes to job hunting in our 20s. I think that this topic definitely doesn't get
我认为，这种与失业和持续求职作斗争的经历，那种必须把一切都弄清楚的压力，那种必须安排好一份充实且有回报的工作、一份充实且有回报的职业的压力，在这个时代真的让人感觉越来越不可能。所以我想谈谈这个话题，我想帮你理解背后的科学，不仅要明白为什么这么难，还要明白为什么在二十岁求职时会有这么多的羞耻感、挫败感，有时甚至有愤怒和怨恨。我认为这个话题绝对没有得到
enough of a spotlight and I'll admit I've even fallen into, I think a bit of complacency myself. I have taken my own circumstances for granted because I was really lucky to kind of fall into something I loved quite early on. I don't think that is the case for everyone. I really think that a more universal experience is one of struggling to find your professional place in the world early on in your career. And just recently, I've had so many friends going through redundancies and periods of unemployment, constant rejections, and it's emotionally challenging. I can see them really struggling with it. So much of our self-esteem and our self-concept is tied to what we do for work. It is tied to how we make money.
足够的关注，我承认自己有时也陷入了一点自满。我把自己的情况视为理所当然，因为我很幸运在很早的时候就碰巧找到了自己热爱的事情。我认为并非每个人都是这样。我真的认为，更普遍的经历是在职业生涯早期努力寻找自己在世界上的职业定位。就在最近，我有这么多的朋友经历裁员和失业期，不断的拒绝，这在情感上是一个挑战。我能看到他们真的很挣扎。我们的自尊和自我概念有很大一部分与我们的工作息息相关。这与我们如何赚钱息息相关，
it is tied to our sense of purpose. So when that is taken away from us or it's unavailable, no matter how hard we try, no matter how many job applications we put out, we feel firstly quite aimless, but secondly, like we have somehow failed in a way that so many others have been successful. We think there must be something wrong with us. We make assumptions about what other people are thinking about us that we're lazy, that we like discipline, that we aren't skilled, when there are so many other explanations for unemployment and struggling with job searching, struggling with your career during this decade. So today we are going to talk about the psychological impact of job hunting,
这与我们的使命感息息相关。所以当这些被剥夺或无法获得时，无论我们多么努力，无论我们投递了多少求职申请，我们首先会感到相当迷茫，其次，我们会觉得自己某种程度上失败了，而其他人却取得了成功。我们认为我们自身一定出了什么问题。我们会对别人如何看待我们做出假设——认为我们懒惰，我们缺乏纪律，我们没有技能，而实际上，对于失业和在这一十年中艰难求职、艰难发展职业生涯，还有无数其他的解释。所以今天我们将讨论求职的心理影响，
unemployment, setbacks and rejections in our 20s, how we can manage our emotional well-being must also staying focused and keeping optimistic about opportunities that come our way. we're also going to talk about concepts like bridging jobs, why there is no shame in doing something that you don't necessarily love for a paycheck, why it's okay to not have a five-year plan, the myth of the dream job, and how to find your purpose during a very confusing period of life. I strongly believe that when we talk openly about these situations, we reduce a lot of the invisible shame we're feeling that I think forces us to keep things to ourselves when they would become so much easier and lighter out in the open.
我们二十岁时的失业、挫折和拒绝，我们如何在保持专注和对迎面而来的机会保持乐观的同时，管理好我们的情感健康。我们还将讨论诸如过渡性工作之类的概念，为什么为了薪水去做一件你未必热爱的事情并不可耻，为什么没有五年计划也没关系，梦想工作的神话，以及如何在人生一个非常混乱的时期找到你的目标。我坚信，当我们公开谈论这些情况时，我们就能减轻许多我们感受到的无形羞耻感，我认为这种羞耻感迫使我们在事情本可以变得更轻松、更开诚布公时，却选择把事情藏在心里。
Trust me, if you're going through this right now, I really cannot express how many people have reached out to me with similar situations. How many friends of mine are going through this? Some of them even in their late 20s, early 30s, and even broader than that, how every single trend is pointing to this being more difficult for this generation, to this being harder. It is not just you. promise. So we're going to slow it down. We're going to look at the psychology. We're going to
相信我，如果你现在正经历这一切，我真的无法表达有多少人联系我诉说类似的情况。我有多少朋友正在经历这些？他们中的一些人甚至已经快三十岁了，甚至三十岁出头，甚至范围更广，每一个趋势都表明这对这一代人来说更加困难，这变得更加艰难。不仅仅是你。我保证。所以我们要放慢脚步。我们要研究心理学。我们要
talk all about it and hopefully make you feel a little bit better about your situation. So all of that and more after this short break. We talk about it a lot on this show, but there is definitely this unspoken pressure in our 20s to know what we are doing with our lives. There is an emphasis on having a five-year plan, on having a dream job, financial independence, job security. That can feel really suffocating if that just hasn't been your path so far or perhaps you just don't want it to be. I think I will continue to repeat this for as long as I can, but this decade, our 20s, is a period of flux and that is both a blessing and a curse. It is this time in our life where there is so much available to us, but all of our timelines, the timelines of yourself and everybody around you is, splintering. For the first like 18, 19 years of our lives, we were in school. We are typically
讨论这一切，并希望能让你对自己的处境感觉好一点。这一切以及更多内容，将在简短的广告之后继续。我们在节目中经常讨论这一点，但在我们二十岁的时候，确实存在一种无言的压力，那就是必须知道我们在生活中在做什么。人们强调要有一个五年计划，要有一份梦想的工作，财务独立，工作稳定。如果这恰好不是你一直以来的道路，或者也许你根本不想这样，那会让人感到非常窒息。我想我会尽可能长时间地重复这一点，但这个十年，我们的二十岁，是一个处于动荡的时期，这既是福也是祸。这是我们生命中的一段时期，有如此多的可能性向我们敞开，但我们所有的时间线——你和周围每个人的时间线——都在碎裂。在我们生命的前18、19年里，我们在上学。我们通常
doing the same things in the same environment with the same ultimate goal as everybody around us, which is to graduate before we kind of get stuck into the real world. It is very structured, it is very uniform, very repetitive for each and all of us. When we walk across the stage, when we graduate, suddenly, after 18 years of always having somebody tell us what is next, what the requirements of moving forward are, we have agency and choice and freedom to choose where we want to go, who we want to be. And the goalposts kind of disappear. Maybe you do end up going to university and the goalposts are kind of reinstated, but only for another three, for maybe five years. At some point, school is going to kind of spit you out into the world
在相同的环境、相同的最终目标下做着相同的事情，那就是毕业，然后我们才会陷入真实的世界。这一切都非常有组织、非常统一、对我们每个人来说都非常重复。当我们走过舞台，当我们毕业时，突然间，在经历了18年总是有人告诉我们下一步是什么、前进的要求是什么之后，我们有了代理权、选择权和自由去选择我们想去哪里，我们想成为谁。而终点线却似乎消失了。也许你最终确实上了大学，终点线在某种程度上又恢复了，但也仅仅持续另外三到五年左右。在某个时刻，学校终究会把你“吐”进这个世界，
and you have to kind of figure out a way of operating in this new environment, one that, you know, I do think the education system doesn't really get us prepared for. You know, it's not just about grades and assignments anymore. You have to put into practice everything that you've learned and there will definitely be a learning curve and it's only natural to be struggling with that. this whole period in the field of psychology is known as emerging adulthood. And the word emerging there is really important because I think it highlights how transitionary this period is. It is not the final chapter.
你必须想办法在这个新环境中运作，老实说，我认为教育系统并没有真正让我们为此做好准备。你知道，这不再仅仅是关于成绩和作业了。你必须将你所学的一切付诸实践，这绝对会有一个学习曲线，为此而挣扎是很自然的。在心理学领域，整个时期被称为“新兴成年期”。其中“新兴”这个词真的很重要，因为它突显了这个过渡期的过渡性。这不是最后一章，
It is the first chapter in a very long life, in a very long career, hopefully. I think that there is not one thing about our career during this decade that is permanent. the jobs that you're applying for, for example, they could not exist in like 20 years. The unpaid internships, eventually you won't have to do them anymore. The terrible bosses, one day you will quit that job and you will find something more meaningful and purposeful. The job interviews, the confusion, eventually that will go away. Eventually it will become more clear to you what you want to do, where you want to be,
而是一个漫长人生、漫长职业生涯的第一章，希望如此。我认为在这个十年里，我们职业生涯中没有什么是永久的。例如，你正在申请的工作在20年后可能根本就不存在了。无薪实习，最终你将不再需要做它们。糟糕的老板，总有一天你会辞掉那份工作，找到更有意义、更有目的的事情。工作面试，困惑，最终这些都会消散。最终你会更清楚自己想做什么，想在哪里，
who you want to be. But all of those things that we really struggle with, they are to be expected. When we're kind of first starting out, I think the misconception that makes us feel really terrible is that this will be like this forever, right? We are always going to feel this lost. We are always going to feel this aimless, this purposeless. We're always going to be in this state of striving for an opportunity. But secondly to that, that it is an us problem, not a societal one. So when I was researching this episode, I came across to, two articles that were super enlightening when it came to this exact point.
你想成为谁。但所有这些让我们真正挣扎的事情，都是意料之中的。当我们刚开始的时候，我认为那个让我们感觉非常糟糕的误解是，这种情况会永远持续下去，对吗？我们将永远感到如此迷失。我们将永远感到如此漫无目的、毫无目标。我们将永远处于为一个机会而奋斗的状态中。但其次，这是一个我们自身的问题，而不是一个社会的问题。所以当我在研究这一集时，我遇到了两篇文章，对于这个确切的观点非常有启发意义。
Job hunting and a lack of success that many of us are experiencing is a societal problem rather than an individual one. So the first article was published by the BBC last year and it essentially said nearly all young workers, so people between 18 and 30, are struggling to cope with economic uncertainty, but also the instability of the job market. And what this article said was that about 91% of us are experiencing or have experienced at least one instant of stress around our future career and our future job insecurity or security in the last six months. Ninety one of, you know, what 91% of us in our 20s essentially are feeling like very much unstable and unsure of,
求职和我们许多人正在经历的缺乏成功是一个社会问题，而不是个人问题。第一篇文章是去年由BBC发表的，它基本上说，几乎所有的年轻工人，也就是18到30岁的人，都在努力应对经济的不确定性，以及就业市场的不稳定性。这篇文章说，我们大约91%的人在过去六个月里经历过或正在经历至少一次关于未来职业和未来工作不稳定（或安全）的压力。你知道，我们20多岁的人中有91%的人基本上都感到非常不稳定和不确定，
of what is next. A lot of this also came down to three large scale stresses. A, fewer entry-level jobs. That is a proven fact. There are less opportunities for people who are junior or just starting out to get their foot in the door. B, increasing competition for a smaller pool of opportunities. It's not just that there are more people who want a smaller amount of jobs, but that those people are more educated, more proficient, have done more internships, have more job experience than ever before, and see there is this rising cost of living, which means that even if you do get one of those coveted entry-level jobs, even if you do surpass all those dozens, hundreds of others, you still might not be able to pay your bills.
接下来会发生什么。这很大程度上也归咎于三个大规模的压力源。A，入门级工作减少。这是一个被证实的事实。对于初级或刚刚起步的人来说，敲开大门的机会更少了。B，较少机会池的竞争加剧。不仅是想要较少工作的人变多了，而且这些人受过更好的教育、更有能力、做过更多实习、拥有比以往任何时候都多的工作经验；C，生活成本不断上升，这意味着即使你得到了其中一个令人垂涎的入门级工作，即使你确实超越了所有这几十个、数百个其他人，你可能仍然付不起账单。
That is one component of why this is so increasingly stressful. The second article was from Time magazine, and it was titled, You're Not Imagining It, Job Hunting is Getting Worse. I'm going to leave a link to this article in the description, because if this describes your experience, you need to read this article. And what they explain is that the tightening kind of labor market, not to make this like an economic podcast rather than a psychological one, but we'll get to the psychology, I promise. Essentially, the tightening labor market has triggered two changes. Firstly, because a lot of companies are really scared about a recession, they take a lot more time to choose people that they're hiring because they want to make sure that they are choosing the right person. Something that we may not realize is that we obviously know it costs money to employ people, but it actually costs also a significant amount of money to find the people that we want to employ. And so companies are just getting a lot more stingy and a lot more cautious.
这就是为什么这变得越来越有压力的一个组成部分。第二篇文章来自《时代》杂志，标题是《你没有想象错，求职正变得越来越糟》。我会在说明栏里留下这篇文章的链接，因为如果这描述了你的经历，你需要读读这篇文章。他们解释说，正在收紧的劳动力市场——不是要把这变成一个经济学播客而不是心理学播客，但我保证我们会讲到心理学。基本上，收紧的劳动力市场引发了两个变化。首先，因为许多公司对经济衰退感到非常害怕，他们花了更多的时间来挑选他们正在招聘的人，因为他们想确保他们选对了人。我们可能没有意识到的一点是，我们显然知道雇用员工需要花钱，但实际上找到我们想要雇用的员工也需要花费相当大的一笔钱。因此，公司变得更加吝啬和谨慎。
I have heard stories of people doing like three or four levels of interviews for entry-level jobs. My friend Emily, she is applying for jobs in the public service in Australia at the moment. She went through three interviews for an entry-level position, and she didn't hear anything for two months. And eventually they'd like offered her the job, but she was like, it's been two months. I can't wait for that long. So they're kind of like back to the drawing board. companies are just taking longer than making you jump through more extravagant and extreme hoops. The second element of this is that because the job market is becoming more limited,
我听说过有人为入门级工作进行三到四轮面试的故事。我的朋友埃米莉，她目前正在澳大利亚申请公共服务工作。她为一个入门级职位经历了三次面试，两个月都没有听到任何消息。最终他们好像给她提供了一份工作，但她说，已经过去两个月了。我不能等那么久。所以他们有点像回到画板前重新开始。公司只是花更长的时间，让你跳过更多奢侈和极端的圈套。这其中的第二个要素是，由于就业市场变得越来越有限，
more experienced and educated people are now applying for the kind of jobs that used to be reserved for individuals like fresh out of uni. You know, there has been mass redundancies across tech, across so many other industries that has meant that people with master's degrees and multiple bachelor's degrees who have five to ten years of experience, they're getting replaced by AI, they're getting let go of, and they have to start again, along with people like you and I, people in their 20s who are starting out for the first time. I know that this has taken a very pessimistic turn. I am sorry, this is not the empowering pump-up speech that I wanted for this episode,
更有经验和受过更高教育的人现在正在申请那些曾经为刚毕业的个人保留的工作。你知道，科技行业以及许多其他行业的规模化裁员意味着，拥有硕士学位和多个学士学位、拥有5到10年经验的人被人工智能取代，被解雇，他们不得不和像你我这样第一次开始的20多岁的人一起重新开始。我知道这已经变成了一个非常悲观的转向。我很抱歉，这不是我想要的那种鼓舞人心的打气演讲，
but all of this is just to say, I promise it's not. not just you. It is systematic. It is just as hard for so many other people out there. I'm hoping that that is a comforting statement to hear, right? That you might be putting a lot of pressure on yourself. You might be feeling terrible, that it's you, that you don't have what it takes, that you're being lazy, that no one likes you, that it's a personal thing when actually across the board people are struggling with this. It's a really hard time to be new to the job market and unemployed. So there are some really tangible, real and true psychological and emotional consequences that come with being stuck in this limbo jobless period. You know, perhaps taking on bridging roles to make
但所有这些只是想说，我向来保证这不是只有你一个人在经历。这是系统的。对于外面的许多其他人来说，这也同样艰难。我希望这是一个令人安慰的声明，对吧？你可能给自己施加了很大的压力。你可能感觉很糟糕，觉得问题出在你身上，觉得你没有能力，觉得你很懒，觉得没人喜欢你，觉得这是一件个人的事情，而实际上各行各业的人都在为此苦苦挣扎。对于刚刚进入就业市场和失业的人来说，这是一个非常艰难的时期。因此，陷入这种无人问津的失业期确实会带来一些切实、真实且深远的心理和情感后果。你知道，也许为了赚钱而承担过渡性的角色，
money, not fully satisfied or sure when one of these countless interviews or resumes is going to hit the desk of the right person. It's a waiting game. And I'm sure you know this already, but there are a lot of ways that this bleeds into our well-being, into our state, our mental state, essentially. And I want to talk about four of the main ways that we can see this in our lives and how to address it before it gets out of hand. Firstly, job hunting, it is a lot of effort from building your resume to finding jobs whose criteria and requirements you match to cover letters, to interviews, to references, sometimes most of the time doing this for multiple opportunities at a time with little payout,
并不完全满意，也不确定这无数次面试或简历中的哪一份会落到合适的人的桌子上。这是一场等待的游戏。我确信你已经知道了这一点，但这在很多方面渗透到我们的福祉中，渗透到我们的状态中，基本上是我们的精神状态。我想谈谈我们可以看到这在我们生活中体现的四种主要方式，以及如何在它失控之前解决它。首先，求职需要付出大量的努力——从建立简历，到寻找符合其标准和要求的职位，到求职信、面试、推荐信，有时大多数时候是同时为多个机会做这些事情，回报却很少，
that is bound to get exhausting. There comes a point where we hit a wall and it's actually called the law of diminishing return. Essentially what it means that at some point, no matter how much we put into an activity, say a job hunt, the output, getting a job, doesn't change. At a certain level, there is only so much effort we can put in before we become disheartened, before we can't give any more, and we're not getting the outcome that we want. And this can lead to two distinct feelings, resentment and pessimism. Resentment, firstly, because we feel like the system is unfair. We feel like we deserve some reward for what we're putting in, how much we want it, how much harder we're working than other people who are
这势必会让人筋疲力尽。总会有一个时刻，我们会撞上一堵墙，这实际上被称为“收益递减规律”。基本上它的意思是，在某个时刻，无论我们在一项活动（比如求职）中投入多少，产出（找到工作）都不会改变。在一定程度上，在我们感到沮丧之前，在我们再也无法付出之前，我们能投入的努力是有限的，而且我们也没有得到想要的结果。这会导致两种截然不同的感觉：怨恨和悲观。首先是怨恨，因为我们觉得这个系统是不公平的。我们觉得我们所投入的、我们有多渴望它、我们比那些看似轻而易举就获得这些机会的人工作得有多努力，理应得到一些回报。我知道这不是一种好的感觉，这是一种非常羞耻的感觉，但这是我们确实会经历的感觉，看到别人得到了我们想要的机会，并对此感到有点心烦意乱。当事情总是朝着同一个方向发展，当我们没有听到回音，当我们没有得到想要的反应时，我们会形成一种心理态度或期望，即情况会继续保持大致相同。陷入这种精神上的泥潭，很难爬出来，因为你继续前进所需的努力和辛苦工作并没有得到强化。作为人类，我们确实非常依赖强化。总会有一个时刻，是的，我们的期望
getting these opportunities seemingly easily. I know it's not a good feeling and it's a very shameful feeling, but it is a feeling that we do experience, seeing other people get the opportunities that we wanted and feeling kind of upset about it. When things just keep going the same way, when we are not hearing back, when we're not getting the response that we want, we're develop a mental attitude or an expectation that it's going to continue much the same. Getting into that mental rut, it can be really hard to climb out of because your efforts and your hard work that is required to, you know, keep going are not being reinforced. And as humans, we do really thrive off of reinforcement. There does come a point where, yeah, our expectations are
会被打破。我们的希望会落入垃圾桶。这只会让人觉得我们绝对没有希望了。我懂。我完全懂。我想说的是，有时这只是一场数字游戏。这只是关于回应广告，回应，你知道的，电话然后忘记它。我有一个朋友说“发了就忘”。我认为这是一个很好的表达方式。她是一名演员，我知道这有点不同，但有一天我问她关于她去过的一个广告的事，我说，嘿，那个电话广告怎么样了？她说，你在说什么？我说，你知道的，你去了，你知道的，你去试镜了。她说，不，你不认为，你不应该去想它，除非你得到积极的反馈，否则不要去想它，因为这可以保持你的期望很低，这样你就不会不断提高你的期望，当你认为这个会起作用时，你认为这个会是那个，然后它不是，你又回到了那种失败的心态中，你继续感到你的努力受到了负面惩罚，你觉得没有希望。求职之所以这么难的第二个原因归结为不断地
going to be dashed. Our hopes are going to be in the dumpster. And it's just going to feel like there is absolutely no hope for us. I get it. I totally get it. And I want to say that sometimes though, it is just a numbers game. It is just about responding to the adverts, responding to, you know, the calls and forgetting about it. I had a friend who says post and ghost. I think that's a great way to put it. she's an actor and I know it's a little bit different but the other day I was asking her about this advert that she went for I was like hey how did that like phone advert go and she was like what are you talking about and I was like you know you went in you know you went in auditioned she was like no you don't think you're not meant to think about it don't think about it unless you get a positive response because it keeps your expectations low so that you don't keep spiking your expectations when you think that this one's going to wear out you think that this one's going to be the one and then it's not and you fall back into that failure mindset you continue to be feel like you are being negatively punished for your efforts you feel like there is no hope the second reason job hunting is so hard comes down to the constant
将会破灭。我们的希望将化为泡影。我们会觉得完全看不到希望。我懂，我完全懂。我想说的是，有时候这真的只是一个概率问题。这仅仅关乎回复广告，回复那些电话，然后把它抛在脑后。我有个朋友说过“发布就忘”。我觉得这总结得太好了。她是一名演员，我知道这有点不同，但前几天我问她关于她去应聘的一个广告的事，我说，嘿，那个手机广告怎么样了？她却说，你在说什么呢？我说，你知道的，就是你去面试的那次，她却说，不，你不能去想，除非得到积极的反馈，否则不要去想，因为这样可以保持较低的期望值，这样当你以为这次会成功、以为这次就是那个机会而结果却不然时，你就不会不断地拉高期望，然后又落入那种失败的心态中，你会继续觉得自己的努力受到了负面的惩罚，你会觉得毫无希望。求职之所以如此艰难的第二个原因归结于不断地
rejection maybe you are lucky enough to get the first job you apply for but that is the exception and not the rule. Most of us will receive about six to ten rejections before we get a job offer according to Forbes. Rejection is such a heavy emotion. It is such a primal state because we are hardwired to avoid it at all costs. Rejection on a very basic level signifies a lack of approval from those whose opinion we value. And when that is repeated, we begin to internalize a number of secondary assumptions about ourselves, that we are not good enough, that we are not as intelligent as we thought, we're not capable, that we have failures. And that hurts our ego. Our ego is related to our confidence. When our confidence is low, that can really interfere with what jobs we apply
拒绝。也许你足够幸运，能得到你申请的第一份工作，但那是特例，而不是规则。根据福布斯的说法，我们大多数人在得到工作机会之前都会收到大约六到十次拒绝。拒绝是一种非常沉重的情绪。它是一种非常原始的状态，因为我们天生就要不惜一切代价避免它。在一个非常基础的层面上，拒绝象征着缺乏那些我们珍视其观点的人的认可。当这种情况重复时，我们开始内化关于我们自己的一系列二次假设，即我们不够好，我们不如想象中那么聪明，我们没有能力，我们是失败者。这伤害了我们的自 ego。我们的自尊与自信息息相关。当我们的自信心低下时，这确实会干扰我们申请什么工作，
for, how secure we come across in interviews, because we begin to believe that these rejections are in some ways defining us, that somehow these other people must know. that we're getting desperate. They must know that like all these other companies rejected us. And that kind of begins to overwhelm what we do actually bring to the table, our wonderful qualities, our wonderful assets. I think it's even worse when you just don't get any feedback at all. You don't receive anything.
我们在面试中显得多么自信，因为我们开始相信这些拒绝在某些方面定义了我们，某种程度上这些其他人一定知道。我们变得绝望。他们一定知道像所有这些其他公司都拒绝了我们。这开始压倒我们真正带到桌面上来的东西，我们美好的品质，我们美好的资产。我认为，当你根本没有得到任何反馈时，情况甚至更糟。你什么也没收到。
Honestly, the places that just ghost you are awful, especially when you are young and especially like when they just don't have the empathy to remember what it was like to be in your position when you could really benefit from the feedback you could benefit from having some closure and not still thinking about that job in two months not still thinking you had a chance two things to counteract the rejection treadmill that it sometimes feels like we're on firstly after each disappointment do something kind for yourself so there is this brilliant article published by Psychology Today that I'll also link in the description and this doctor, her name is Dr. Gina Schneider, she said something so perfect about this. Looking for a job can feel
老实说，那些直接对你玩“失踪”的地方太糟糕了，特别是当你年轻的时候，特别是当他们没有同理心去记住处于你的位置是什么感觉时，当你真的可以从反馈中受益时，你可以从有一些了结中受益，而不是两个月后还在想那份工作，两个月后还觉得自己有机会。这里有两件事可以用来对抗这种有时感觉我们身处其中的拒绝跑步机：首先，在每次失望之后，为自己做一件好事。因此，《今日心理学》发表了一篇精彩的文章，我也会在说明栏里链接它，这位医生，她的名字叫吉娜·施耐德博士（Dr. Gina Schneider），她关于这一点说得太完美了。寻找工作会让人觉得
like a punishing experience. We look at the prize that is getting the job as the only reward for all the work. Instead, you need to provide ample rewards for all your job hunting efforts. apply for the job, then give yourself a break to have fun. Go through your fourth interview, take a friend to dinner. Go and go for a walk, get out of your head. Tell yourself, you will reward yourself with like a small treat after preparing for a lengthy interview, after finishing that ruling cover letter or case study. I think rewarding yourself for the effort, not the outcome, helps you maintain that
这是一次惩罚性的经历。我们将获得工作视为所有工作的唯一奖励。相反，你需要为你的所有求职努力提供充足的奖励。申请工作，然后给自己一个休息的时间去玩乐。经历第四次面试，带朋友去吃晚饭。出去走走，把思绪从脑海中赶走。告诉自己，在为冗长的面试做准备、完成那份费力的求职信或案例研究后，你会用一个小礼物来奖励自己。我认为为努力而不是结果奖励自己，有助于你保持那种
motivation and that momentum that you really need. It's also valuable to remember that it's not always about you. Of course we are at the center of our own universe. That's how it is. We are the only person who we truly can understand. And even then, we don't really understand ourselves fully. But it's our reality that we are most aware of. And so we tend to think every failure or rejection must relate back to something that was wrong with us, something that we were lacking. that we did incorrectly. Instead, I want you to consider this concept or this kind of like idea I came across called the mustard effect.
你真正需要的动力和势头。记住这并不总是关于你，这也是很有价值的。当然，我们处于自己宇宙的中心。事情就是这样。我们是唯一真正能理解的人。即便如此，我们也没有真正完全理解自己。但这是我们最意识到的现实。因此，我们倾向于认为每一次失败或拒绝都必须追溯到我们身上出了什么问题，我们有什么欠缺。
So the mustard effect came from the story of a really talented actor who went to meet with the director for a new movie. He was perfect for the role. He was like the leading man of the day, super attractive, talented, perfect like resume. But right as he got to the restaurant, The director he was meeting spilled mustard on his favorite shirt. And he was so frustrated, he was so distracted that he passed on the actor. He didn't offer him the movie.
我们做错了什么。相反，我希望你考虑这个概念或我想到的这个想法，叫做“芥末效应”。芥末效应来自一个非常有才华的演员的故事，他去见一位新电影的导演。他非常适合这个角色。他就像当时的男主角，超级有吸引力、有才华、完美的简历。但就在他到达餐厅的时候，他见到的导演把芥末洒在了他最喜欢的衬衫上。他太沮丧了，太分心了，以至于他没有选择这个演员。他没有给他拍电影的机会。
You can be the most amazing candidate and sometimes the recruiter is just in a bad mood. There is just someone a tad bit more experience than you in something really niche that they need. Somebody spills mustard. So try not to take it too personally. sometimes it's not even like the disappointment and the exhaustion of the constant efforts and the letdowns. It's the simple fact that not having a job means we can't do certain things that truly bring us joy and that fill our cup because we simply don't have the money for them. When you are watching all of your friends buy new clothes, go out for dinner, book vacations, that can't be a very nice feeling as much as we try. Try and suppress it. Enmy is an especially loud emotion. So I don't blame you. It's hard to
你可以成为最优秀的候选人，有时招聘人员只是心情不好。只是有一个在他们需要的非常小众的领域比你多一点经验的人。有人洒了芥末。所以尽量不要太个人化。有时甚至不是不断的努力和失望带来的失望和疲惫。简单的事实是，没有工作意味着我们无法做某些真正给我们带来快乐和充实我们的杯子的事情，因为我们根本没有钱。当你看着所有的朋友买新衣服、出去吃晚饭、预订假期时，这绝不是一种美好的感觉，无论我们怎么努力。尝试去压抑它。嫉妒是一种特别响亮的情绪。所以我不怪你。很难
see everybody else living perhaps a life of ease while you're still struggling. You know, this day and age, it is the age of social comparison. Of course we are going to compare paychecks. Of course we are going to compare career progression, job titles, or lack thereof. Because all of those things serve as proxies for what we see as progress. Our jobs also bring a sense of purpose and productivity. Like we can say we're doing something, that our degrees were worth something, those internships, those extracurriculars, those, you know, stupid jobs that we didn't want to do, it was all worth it because we have something to do with our days. And when we don't have that, there is definitely a level of shame and stigma, I think we implicitly feel. We're adults. This is what we should be doing.
看到其他人可能过着轻松的生活，而你还在挣扎。你知道，在这个时代，这是社交比较的时代。我们当然会比较薪水。我们当然会比较职业晋升、职位头衔或缺乏这些。因为所有这些东西都作为我们视为进步的代理。我们的工作也带来了一种目标感和生产力。就像我们可以说我们正在做某事，我们的学位是有价值的，那些实习，那些课外活动，那些，你知道的，我们不想做的愚蠢工作，这一切都是值得的，因为我们的日子里有事情可做。当我们没有这个时，我认为我们含蓄地感到某种程度的羞耻和耻辱。我们是成年人。这是我们应该做的。
This is what we were always taught we should be doing. We should have a job. That's how we stay useful in society, especially in a society where it's our output that really counts. So I read this story about how in Japan businessmen will actually get dressed up in, you know, in the morning, in their suits, in their ties, they'll take the train to the city, they'll leave their apartments, and they'll just sit in the park all day until they return home because they don't have jobs. And it's not that they're being productive with that time, it's that the shame of not having a job. The shame of being unemployed causes them to want to keep up the facade for those around them. And I think that's not too dissimilar to what you may be experiencing. Shame. A sense that you are
这是我们一直被教导我们应该做的事情。我们应该有一份工作。这就是我们在社会中保持有用性的方式，尤其是在一个真正看重产出的社会中。所以我读过这样一个故事：在日本，商人实际上会在早晨穿好西装，打好领带，坐火车去城市，离开公寓，整天坐在公园里，直到回家，因为他们没有工作。并不是他们在利用这段时间做有成效的事情，而是没有工作的羞耻感。失业的羞耻感让他们想要为周围的人保持这种表象。我认为这与你可能正在经历的并没有太大不同。羞耻。一种你觉得自己
lazy or that you're going to be judged. Obviously, you may not be going as far as to put on a business suit and go and sit in the park all day, but there is perhaps a tendency to conceal things, a tendency to perhaps, I don't know, not want to reveal to your friends or your family that you are struggling, how hard it has been, how many rejections you have gotten, how lost you feel. I also heard this from a lot of friends of mine who are currently on the job hunt looking for a cool thing to do, that there is this tension, this kind of pool between wanting to simply get a job, not wanting to get left behind, wanting to make some money, but also wanting to be happy in what you're doing. And not just settle for the first job that comes your way.
懒惰或会被评判的感觉。很明显，你可能不会走到穿上西装整天去公园坐着的地步，但可能有一种掩盖事情的倾向，一种可能，我不知道，不想向你的朋友或家人透露你正在挣扎，这有多难，你得到了多少拒绝，你感觉多么迷失。我也从许多目前正在求职以寻找一件酷事的正处于求职过程中的朋友那里听到，存在着这种紧张关系，这种想要简单地得到一份工作、不想被抛在后面、想要赚一些钱的拉扯，但也想要对自己在做的事情感到高兴。并且不只是满足于迎面而来的第一份工作。
It feels like a really significant choice. and that is the confusion that also comes along with this. We spend ages trying to find a job, only to have doubts about what might be right for us. I think job hunting is hard enough, but when you add purpose and mission and ambition into the picture, it gets even more complicated. So we're going to take a short break,
这感觉像是一个非常重大的选择。这也是随之而来的困惑。我们花了好长时间试图找到一份工作，却对什么可能适合我们产生怀疑。我认为求职已经够难了，但当你把目标、使命和雄心加入到画面中时，事情就变得更加复杂了。所以我们要休息一下，
but when we come back, we're going to kind of discuss how we can discover purpose whilst also looking for that paycheck, and also how you can lessen the pressure or the mental load of job hunting and the shame when it isn't going your way. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%.
但当我们回来时，我们将讨论如何在寻找薪水的同时发现目标，以及如何在事情不顺时减轻求职的压力或精神负担以及羞耻感。这一切以及更多内容，将在简短的广告之后继续。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health. and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康领域的专家进行对话。和健身专家等等，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上有炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是2%？还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在Look Back at it播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，1984年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备一整天都在谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目，所以我开始看到一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
现在我们面前还有艾滋病，所以。然后你完成了那句话。是的，我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序收听Look Back at it，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《知难而退》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们用记分牌观看生活，生活变成了赢和输史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这里做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
那是两个不同信任水平。我希望你真的能做一个好人。和我一起，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而退》中进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开您的免费iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《知难而退》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父亲身份丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中的明显矛盾。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lusby and Michael Marangini.
你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吧，桑兹女士？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·拉斯比和迈克尔·马朗尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，阿里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在Iheart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，阿里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在Iheart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。
One of my favorite, like, Tumblr, Instagram, that kind of genre of post that I've ever seen, which was quite popular back in the day, but still feels very noteworthy, is. this post that recounts when famous actors and public figures first got their big break. Oprah, for example, got fired from her first reporting job at 23. Harrison Ford, he was a carpenter at 30. Morgan Freeman. He wasn't in like a major movie until he was 52. I'm sure that a lot of us have seen this post, but I think that every time I see it, it is such a simple reminder that the stakes feel really hard.
我见过最喜欢的Tumblr、Instagram这类流派的帖子之一，它在过去非常受欢迎，但现在看来仍然非常引人注目，就是这篇记录著名演员和公众人物何时获得他们重大突破的帖子。例如，奥普拉在23岁时被她的第一份记者工作解雇。哈里森·福特，他在30岁时是一名木匠。摩根·弗里曼。直到52岁他才出演了一部主要电影。我确信我们很多人都看过这篇帖子，但我认为每次我看到它时，它都是一个如此简单的提醒，即赌注感觉真的很艰难。
right now. They feel really significant in our 20s to get it right. But there are so many paths to your dream destination and so many parts of the journey that you just cannot foresee in the moment that you are in right now. I think uncertainty is part of the 20 something package. It's part of the deal. Not knowing what comes next. Feeling like you have these big dreams and not knowing what to do with them, feeling like there are other dreams you have to put on hold out of necessity. That is all kind of part of what this decade promises. So firstly, I want you to take the pressure off a little bit. You don't need to be searching for or working your dream job right now to be happy.
现在。在我们的20多岁时，把事情做好感觉真的很重要。但是通往你梦想目的地的道路有那么多，旅程中有那么多部分，在你所处的当下，你是无法预见的。我认为不确定性是20多岁套餐的一部分。这是交易的一部分。不知道接下来会发生什么。感觉你有着这些伟大的梦想，却不知道该拿它们怎么办，感觉你还有其他梦想出于必要不得不搁置。这可以说是这个十年所承诺的一部分。所以首先，我想让你稍微减轻一点压力。你现在不需要寻找或从事你的梦想工作来获得快乐。
In fact, I personally don't think that the dream job even exists. There is so much hype around this idea that if you love what you do, you never work a day in your life, I think that neglects the wrong. of practicality, just needing something to give you a paycheck, having those intermission periods where you are in transition, like after graduation or when you're making a career jump or after getting fired. It is okay to be working casual jobs in the meantime. It is okay to not necessarily know what comes next. I think this idea of the dream job makes a lot of us feel like if we're not totally sold and in love with what we are doing as a career, we are bound to be
事实上，我个人认为梦想工作根本不存在。人们对这种想法大肆宣传，如果你热爱你所做的事情，你一天都不会觉得是在工作，我认为这忽视了实用性，仅仅需要一份薪水来养活自己，经历那些处于过渡期的间歇期，比如毕业后，或者当你进行职业跨越时，或者被解雇后。在这期间做一些临时工作是可以的。不一定知道接下来会发生什么也是可以的。我认为这种梦想工作的想法让很多人觉得，如果我们没有完全沉浸在并热爱我们作为职业所做的事情，我们注定会
miserable. But it doesn't consider that life is more than work and that sometimes you don't really know what you want to do until much later in life when you have had experience. And maybe that is what this time is right now. It is about experience. It is about applying for jobs you never saw yourself doing and maybe doing them for a couple of months, doing them for a year and just seeing where it takes you. A perspective that I kind of love as an alternative to the dream job concept is this Japanese idea of Ikigai. So that kind of roughly translates to reason for being. I was introduced to this concept through a book that was written about it a couple of years ago by these two authors. And in the process of writing this book, they went to this small town in the Okinawa
痛苦。但这并没有考虑到生活不仅仅是工作，有时直到生活晚期你有了经验，你才真正知道自己想做什么。也许现在就是这样的时刻。这是关于体验的。这是关于申请那些你从未想过自己会去做的 工作，也许做几个月，做一年，看看它会把你带向何方。我作为梦想工作概念的替代品而非常喜欢的一个观点是这个关于“生きがい”（Ikigai）的日本理念。这大致翻译为生存的意义。我是通过几位作者几年前写的一本书接触到这个概念的。在写这本书的过程中，他们去了日本冲绳地区的一个小镇
district in Japan, and it's what is known as a blue zone. So there are a bunch of blue zones around the world. These are essentially locations where the population in those areas are some of the happiest and some of the healthiest and who live the longest. And what they found was that amongst all these kind of like elderly Japanese people, all of them had a sense of Ikai, They had a sense of being. Instead of looking for one thing that is going to light your fire, instead of looking for a job that just pays you a lot of money, or trying exorbitantly hard to just find the one thing that you absolutely love doing
这个地方被称为蓝色地带。所以世界各地有一群蓝色地带。这些基本上是那些地区的人口最幸福、最健康、寿命最长的地方。他们发现，在所有这些日本老年人中，他们都有“生きがい”的意识，他们有一种存在感。不要寻找一件事来点燃你的激情，不要寻找一份只付给你很多钱的工作，或者极其努力地只去寻找一件你绝对热爱的事情
and nothing else at all, focus on asking yourself for specific questions. What do you actually like doing? What do you actually enjoy? What are you good at doing? What do you receive praise for? What do people tell you that? you have a special knack for. What does the world actually need? And what can you get paid for?
而别无其他，专注于问自己四个具体问题。你实际上喜欢做什么？你实际上享受什么？你擅长做什么？你因何受到赞扬？人们对你说过什么？你有什么特殊的诀窍。世界真正需要什么？你能为什么获得报酬？
So if we have like the example of being a psychologist, that might be your dream job. Right now, it's probably going to take like quite a few years of study to get there. Probably a lot of rejections, probably a lot of setbacks. In the interim, you still need to make money. You still want to be doing something. So think about how you can fulfill your Ica guy in other ways. I'm guessing if you want to be a psychologist, you're probably really good at talking to people. You enjoy talking to people. They connect with you. They open up.
所以如果我们以成为心理学家为例，那可能是你的梦想工作。现在，要达到这个目标可能需要好几年的学习。可能会有很多拒绝，可能会有很多挫折。在此期间，你仍然需要赚钱。你仍然想做点事情。所以想想你如何能以其他方式实现你的“生きがい”。我猜如果你想成为一名心理学家，你可能非常擅长与人交谈。你喜欢与人交谈。他们与你建立联系。他们向你敞开心扉。
It feels fulfilling. I think the world needs more people who can hold empathy and space for others. But right now, you can't get paid for it in the specific way that you would like. But if you were a grocery store clerk or a disability support worker, if you worked in customer service, you can still utilize your unique abilities. and gain those vital skills, even if it's not your dream destination. You know, personally, before I did this full time, you know, a lot of people might assume this is my dream job. I didn't even know this existed three years ago. And before I, you know, stumbled into podcasting, I've spoken about how I worked in consulting.
这让人感到充实。我认为世界需要更多能够为他人保持同理心和空间的人。但现在，你无法以你希望的具体方式为此获得报酬。但如果你是一名杂货店店员或残疾支援工作者，如果你从事客户服务工作，你仍然可以利用你独特的才能并获得那些至关重要的技能，即使它不是你的梦想目的地。你知道，在我全职做这个之前，你知道，很多人可能会假设这是我的梦想工作。三年前我甚至不知道这东西存在。在我偶然涉足播客之前，我曾谈到过我曾在咨询行业工作。
And especially I did health consulting and big mental health programs for the government was something that I really focused on. It was not my dream job. but besides that, there was so many things that I took from it that have made my current career so much more fruitful. Obviously, I spoke a lot about mental health during that time, but it also made me really proficient in academic research. It made me really proficient in time management, in science communication, in writing applications for grants and things like that. And I'm so grateful for that now. I think, I firmly believe that our 20s are not our 20s are not our time to be perfect, especially when it comes to our careers and our professional lives. It's a time for experimentation.
特别是从事健康咨询，以及为政府制定的重大心理健康项目是我真正关注的事情。这不是我的梦想工作，但除此之外，我从中汲取了如此多的东西，使我目前的工作更加富有成效。显然，我在那段时期谈论了很多关于心理健康的话题，但这也让我非常擅长学术研究。它使我在时间管理、科学传播、撰写资助申请等方面变得非常熟练。我现在对此非常感激。我认为，我坚信我们的20多岁并不是我们完美的时期，特别是在我们的职业和职业生活方面。这是一个实验的时期。
It's a time for discovery. Your purpose might not be entirely clear to you right now, but that is what this period is for. It's getting to see what's out there. Doing jobs that might not be high on your list of things that you thought you would like doing, applying for those random positions that you've never considered and just seeing what happens. I know that it's very easy to compare to people who seemingly have it all, who are already looking like they're uber successful, but that is again the exception, not the rule.
这是一个发现的时期。你的目标现在可能对你来说还不是很清晰，但这就是这段时期的目的。它是为了看看外面有什么。做那些可能在你认为你会喜欢做的事情的名单上排名不高的工作，申请那些你从未考虑过的随机职位，看看会发生什么。我知道很容易与那些表面上拥有一切、看起来已经超级成功的人进行比较，但这同样是特例，而不是规则。
Another component of the job hunt of unemployment in our 20s is taking on roles where you are just going to have to swallow the toad. You are going to have to start from the bottom and maybe do things that you don't necessarily want to do, but it can lead you to, to something bigger. When you look at those people you might see online who you think, oh my God, they have it all together. What did they do differently? What did they do that I didn't do? You have to remember that they might just be a few steps ahead of you.
求职和20多岁失业的另一个组成部分是承担那些你不得不咽下苦果的角色。你将不得不从底层做起，也许做一些你不一定想做的事情，但它可以引导你走向更伟大的事物。当你看着你在网上看到的那些人，你可能会想，天哪，他们把一切都处理得井井有条。他们做了什么不同的事？他们做了什么我没做的事？你必须记住，他们可能只是比你领先了几步。
Or they may have had networks. They may have had shortcuts. Or they may have done these tedious, unfulfilling jobs that you're doing now that are actually really valuable. Because they give you that work ethic that doesn't disappear the older you get. and they give you those connections, they give you that experience. You just have to start somewhere, even if it's not where you imagined yourself starting. Some final tips for managing both the stress and the practicality of job hunting in our 20s.
或者他们可能有关系网。他们可能有捷径。或者他们可能做了你现在正在做的这些繁琐的、没有成就感的工作，而这些工作实际上非常宝贵。因为它们赋予了你随着年龄增长而不会消失的职业道德，而且它们为你提供了这些联系，为你提供了这种经验。你必须从某处开始，即使它不是你想象中开始的地方。关于管理20多岁求职的压力和实用性的一些最后建议。
Firstly, find someone else who is going through the same thing and meet up with them to job hunt, to write cover letters, to write applications together. Treat the job hunt like a job. like there is structure like there are things and KPI's and you know tasks that you need to tick off so you don't feel like this is a waste of time so you don't feel like this is just an endless cycle of not knowing of effort and setbacks but alongside that when you do it with somebody else you have that support you kind of have somebody almost like a colleague or a co-worker a co-worker in your job hunt to complain to and to kind of just how have a whine to about how rough it is and to know that they experiencing, they are experiencing the same thing. It also just obviously helps combat loneliness of unemployment as well, which is a big thing. Secondly, don't be afraid to tell people that you are looking for work. Not only does this train us out of the feeling of shame, which is important. There is no shame in just getting started
首先，找一个正在经历同样事情的人，和他们见面一起求职，一起写求职信，一起写申请。把求职当成一份工作。就像有结构一样，有事情、关键绩效指标（KPI）以及你需要勾选的任务，这样你才不会觉得这是在浪费时间，才不会觉得这只是一场不知所措、付出努力却遭遇挫折的无休止循环，但与此同时，当你和别人一起做这件事时，你得到了支持，你几乎拥有了一个像同事或工作伙伴一样的人，一个和你一起求职的伙伴，你可以向他抱怨，向他发牢骚，抱怨生活有多么艰难，并知道他们也在经历着同样的事情。这显然也有助于消除失业带来的孤独感，这也是一个大问题。其次，不要害怕告诉别人你在找工作。这不仅让我们摆脱了羞耻感，这很重要。开始行动并努力寻找适合自己的工作并没有什么羞耻感
and trying to find what's right for you. But I think when we are vulnerable about something that we don't like to speak about, people feel a natural inclination to help. And there is a natural like eliciting of empathy. They will, I think, connect you with new people. They will connect you with places that are hiring, with friends that they know in the industry, with opportunities that they've heard of.
但是我认为，当我们对一件我们不喜欢谈论的事情表现出脆弱时，人们会产生一种天然的帮助倾向。并且会自然而然地激发同理心。我认为他们会把你和新的人联系起来。他们会把你和正在招聘的地方、他们认识的业内朋友以及他们听说过的工作机会联系起来。
people want to be in your corner, those empathy centres in our brain start lighting up when we see somebody else who is not only struggling but as being open and sensitive about that struggle. Finally, I want you to know that it will happen even if it is taking time, even if you're going slower than you imagined, even if you are not where you thought you'd be. No one wakes up a success. So many success stories start with shitty jobs. start with being broke, start with not having the perfect job or any job at all. There are so many steps in between where you are now and where you want to be in the future.
人们希望站在你这一边，当我们看到另一个人不仅在苦苦挣扎，而且对这种挣扎表现得开放和敏感时，我们大脑中的同理心中心就开始被点亮。最后，我想让你知道这会发生，即使它需要时间，即使你的进展比你想象的要慢，即使你没有达到你认为自己会呆的地方。没有人一觉醒来就成了成功人士。许多成功故事都始于糟糕的工作。始于破产，始于没有完美的工作或根本没有工作。在你现在的处境和你未来想要达到的目标之间，还有很多步骤。
And I don't know, as someone who went through like periods of unemployment and who worked, terrible jobs and who got rejected from so many jobs and so many internships, there will come a point where you do get to look back and be like, you get to tell the story in hindsight and it feels kind of magical that you got to where you are. and you do feel in some ways grateful for the lessons that you learn and the fact that you didn't just come to you easily that you actually had to try and work hard and test yourself. Every small piece, every small thing that you are doing, every small action is contributing to the process, it's contributing to you, getting a job, finding your career path,
而且我不知道，作为一个经历过失业期、做过糟糕的工作、被无数工作和实习拒绝过的人，总会有一个时刻，你可以回过头来想，你可以事后讲述这个故事，你会觉得你到达今天的位置有点神奇。而且你在某种程度上对你所学的教训以及事情并没有轻易降临到你身上、你实际上不得不尝试努力工作并考验自己的事实感到感激。每一个小部分，你做的每一件小事，每一个微小的行动都在为这个过程做出贡献，它在为你找工作、寻找职业道路做出贡献，
figuring out what you want to do, but right now it doesn't have to be perfect. you are doing enough, you are doing the best you can, and I'm just sending a lot of love. I'm sending a lot of encouragement and support your way because I know it is tough when everyone around you seems to have it together, when you're broke, when you don't have the money for the opportunities that you would like to be pursuing, when it feels like you wasted all your time in uni and college
弄清楚你想做什么，但现在它不需要是完美的。你已经做得很好了，你正在尽你所能，我只是送去很多爱。我向你发送了很多鼓励和支持，因为我知道当周围每个人看起来都生活得很完美，当你破产了，当你没有钱去追求你想要追求的机会，当感觉你浪费了你在大学里的所有时间时，这真的很艰难。
and nobody wants you, it's temporary. Something will come your way, I am sure. of it. So I really hope that this episode has been of some solace to you or has at least provided you with some new information, something else to consider, some tips, some tricks, some comfort. As always, if there is somebody that you know in your life who is also job hunting, firstly maybe hit them up and start applying for some jobs together. It's a great idea. Otherwise, share this episode with them. Maybe they'll get something out of it as well. Make sure that you are following along. I post so many different episodes, so many different concepts, ideas,
而且没有人想要你，这只是暂时的。总会有好事降临到你身上的，我对此深信不疑。所以我真的希望这期节目能给你带来一些慰藉，或者至少为你提供了一些新的信息、一些需要考虑的事情、一些小贴士、一些小把戏、一些安慰。像往常一样，如果你生命中认识某人也正在找工作，首先也许联系他们并开始一起申请一些工作。这是个好主意。否则，把这期节目分享给他们。也许他们也能从中得到一些收获。确保你一直在关注。我发布了这么多不同的剧集，这么多不同的概念、想法，
so many different aspects of our 20s. And I'm always looking for episode suggestions. So feel free to DM me at That Psychology Podcast with your thoughts, your feelings, your questions, your qualms, whatever it is. I would love to hear from you. And as always, until we see you next week, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very soon. on The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
我们20多岁的许多不同方面。我一直在寻找剧集建议。所以请随时通过私信将你的想法、感受、问题、疑虑或任何事情发送到“那个心理学播客”（That Psychology Podcast）。我很乐意听到你的消息。一如既往，直到下周见，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会在《回顾它》播客中交谈。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过它的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾它》。嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《硬核学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真正不安全的诚实对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast, In 2020, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
但你正在和一个知道自己在做什么的获得执照的专业人士进行交流。有多少人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《硬核学习》。2020年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
被指控生了双胞胎，但怀孕似乎是个骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Grega lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, and use, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
格雷戈·莱斯比。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是陷入爱河。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Listen to a love trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健康和恢复力的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会从另一端走出来。一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。那是“TWO%”。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子发表评论。